the Joe Rogan experience there was a lot
of third party voters in the last
election they don't won the election I
was one of them
Jill Stein Gary Johnson yeah he did my
podcast oh no [ __ ] yeah so I said what
was his deal well he didn't know
government guy anything about that he
was sunk because he didn't know what
where Aleppo was uh yeah um yeah
like people were considering him fairly
serious uh-huh hmm maybe I'm serious
about Gary Johnson he seems fairly
reasonable what he's a reasonable guy
and they asked him what do you think we
do about Aleppo he's like what [ __ ]
Aleppo
yeah that's a City were a lot of bad
checks out but did Trump know where
Aleppo was he doesn't have to he doesn't
have to
they they could say what are you gonna
do about Aleppo he probably where's
Aleppo Syria oh well that place is a
mess
yeah I want no with that I think we're
done with that I think we cancelled them
so Aleppo is in Syria right so where
does I think that's what it is yeah it
was almost like a trick question yeah
you know because who [ __ ] yeah he didn't
know but who does yeah who did I got all
the people like this [ __ ] dude he
doesn't even know where Aleppo is I
didn't know where Aleppo was yeah I
didn't know the question either yeah
obviously I'm not running for president
well we're kind of hoping that that
person knows the [ __ ] we don't or they
tell him when he gets in there but
that's the scary thing about Trump is
that other leaders will have advisors
around them that they trust right tell
them stuff but Trump doesn't seem to
read the who's not interested in that
he's not interested no no they booed the
[ __ ] out of him at the UFC Oh were you
there yeah because because I heard from
one camp that they cheered and from
another camp that they his son said they
cheered for him listen to Daddy
I took my [ __ ] headphones off just to
listen and it was
really yeah man 18,000 people go his son
said they were chanting USA maybe four
people behind him were chanting USA
the rest were saying boo si you know
what Donald Jr said yes you'd probably
say that too look they booed the [ __ ]
out of him yeah I'm sure some people
clapped yeah sure
but if you had if you had a bet your
money on it like what was the greater
percentage was it booze or claps it was
[ __ ] booze yeah dude I took my
headphones off uh-huh I was right there
yeah hit him with a rock he was right
over there yeah boo yeah I'm surprised
he showed up after what happened at the
World Series the same [ __ ] thing
happened a week before um maybe he
figured coz it was DC it was because
it's so liberal in DC they probably
figured cuz it was at the fights yeah
cage fights I mean you know also he's
friends with Dana White and they're good
friends apparently like there were
there's a picture on Dana's Instagram of
him and Donald sitting in front of the
television watching fights they're
watching the prelims before he went out
Dana watches some of the card in his
greenroom listens to the commentary and
you know wants to see so because like
there's a lot of moving pieces involved
being the President of the United States
and also the president of the UFC a lot
of moving pieces you know have a lot of
time to sit through the entire
pay-per-view while you're there so Dana
sits in the back and he watches a lot of
the pay-per-view card on the screen in
his in his office or in his green room
so he was back there with Donald sitting
on the couch and he put it on his
Instagram just watching some fights it's
just him and Trump sitting there that's
hilarious
yeah Wow is watching my friend Corey
Anderson damn knock Johnny Walker so
look at that watching fights like what
you think Dana Dana White's been to [ __ ]
this kid khabib ask him where did my
father visa send location yeah it's his
father can't get a visa
yeah ask Donald bro come on did good
free could be give you got forty six
thousand likes on that
walk into master square garden last
night with Dana White for the big UFC
championship fight was a little bit like
walking into a trump rally plenty of
Magha and KAG present what is KAG oh
okay great energy fantastic job Dana
headed to DC and then to Kentucky for
the big Matt Bevin rally
okay well look for sure some people
cheered for sure for sure for sure some
people waved at him some way the people
look some people were psyched to see him
mmm look if I was in the crowd now
wasn't hammered and he was here I'd be
like what's up okay yell Adam I'd say hi
had wave at him but the reaction like
when he walked in there's a lot of booze
yeah but that's just [ __ ] gonna happen
man he's a controversial character
mm-hmm you know like anywhere he goes
he's gonna give it it's fun to boo yeah
it's fun to go [ __ ] you it's fun you're
gonna do something when you see some of
that you're either gonna cheer you're
gonna bill yam you get Secret Service
all around them there's there was a lot
of noise man a lot of noise but a lot of
it was it wasn't it wasn't like [ __ ]
Trump [ __ ] Trump there was no chant you
know this place is where he can't go
right look if he went to an LBGT rally I
would guarantee yeah that's a place
where he can't go right
even if he's Pro LBGT with his his
policy that's place were they gonna
digging they like pretty University
haynam yeah where where would you say he
can't go where where wouldn't be a good
move I think any kind of a woman's
movement like oh yeah yeah me too
marches yeah what if you addressed like
when they had those women marches were
all wearing the [ __ ] hats and walk down
the street and they have a little speed
they'd set up a stage and he comes out
to address them that's grabbing her
buddy's hat grandmother [ __ ] at
[Applause]